alfred crosby says in america's
forgotten pandemic
the important and almost
incomprehensible fact about the spanish
influenza
is that it killed millions upon millions
of people
in a year or less nothing else
no infection no war no famine has ever
killed
so many in a short a period and yet
it has never inspired awe not in 1918
and not since epidemic diseases have
often
changed the course of human history the
death of a world leader
an epidemic before a great battle but
few diseases have accomplished it
through sheer brute force
the deadliest epidemic of all times
wasn't smallpox wasn't the black
death it was the 1918 flu
in one year an estimated 50 to 100
million people
died and that's out of a global
population of only 1.8 billion
in america alone 675
000 people died of the flu
more americans died of the flu in a
single year than in world war one
world war ii korea and vietnam combined
it was one of the great watershed events
in the history of the world
but it has remained shrouded in a cloud
of silence
ever since the usual explanation is that
world war one took center stage
but it's also true that flu survivors
were so horrified
they didn't want to remember during one
of the most productive periods in
american literature
there are only a few mentions of the flu
thomas wolfe describes the death of his
brother and look homeward angel
and catherine ann porter tells of her
own brush with mortality
and laments the death of her fiance in
pale horse
pale ryder some of the scenes that i'm
going to describe
in our next three lectures will disturb
you
and yet history compels us not to look
away
lest we fail to learn the lessons paid
for by the suffering of our parents
and our grandparents
the 1918 flu also shows us for better or
worse
how society responds to a public health
crisis
and by learning how and why we were so
vulnerable
we may be better equipped to save
ourselves when that next global pandemic
strikes
and if you're upset by the chilling
story that i'm about to tell
ask yourself this if it was so bad
that we can barely stand to hear about
it nearly a century later
how much more horrible must it have been
for those who actually lived through
it and in answering that question
you might also realize the answer to
another question if it was so
terrible why have most of us never even
heard of it
so let's go back in time to a simpler
era before
television before computers before ipods
and the internet
summer of 1918. the us is enjoying warm
weather general prosperity
for most people their biggest worry was
the war in europe world war one
the war to end all wars
the flu had passed through the previous
spring bringing mild fever and eggs but
nothing unusual
most of its victims were among the very
young or the very old
and that's the typical u-shaped curve of
flu mortality
a high incidence of juvenile mortality
not too many people dying in the middle
age groups and then when we get into the
50s and 60s it starts to rise rather
steeply again
and flu is nothing new the first global
flu pandemic goes back to 1580.
it started in asia swept across europe 9
000 people died in rome and many spanish
cities were virtually
depopulated from 1700 to 1900 there had
been at least
16 major epidemics of influenza some of
them deadly
an outbreak in 1729 and 1730 claimed 1
000 lives a week in europe
the last major pandemic was in 1889 to
1890 the first of what were later called
the asian flus why do so many flu
epidemics start in asia
well as we'll learn later on it's
probably due to the large numbers of
people
living in close proximity to large
numbers of chickens and ducks
nobody knows exactly where the 1918 flu
began but evidence points to haskell
county in kansas
where local physician dr loring minor
was seeing dozens of his patients
stricken by an unusually virulent
form of the flu between january and
mid-march
of 1918. as we learned in lecture seven
virulence is a measure of the relative
severity of a disease
usually determined by its mortality rate
by the middle of march the flu had faded
away as quickly
and as mysteriously as it had appeared
but dr minor was so concerned with its
intensity
he reported it to the u.s public health
service who published his cautionary
note
but otherwise ignored it
and there it might have ended except for
one unalterable
fact we were at war
flu victims can spread the disease for
up to a week and in an isolated place
like pascal county the flu might have
quickly died out after being passed back
and forth
among the local population but in
wartime
people are moving between populations
more often and in greater numbers
so the timing of this epidemic could not
have been worse
some 300 miles down the road from
haskell county was camp funston
part of the huge fort riley military
complex
and camp funson had a higher population
than usual due to wartime training
because of the cold weather that year
soldiers were crowded together indoors
with insufficient clothes and blankets
jammed closely around the few working
stoves
and in early march soldiers began to
report to the infirmary with flu-like
symptoms within days several
thousand were stricken but only 38 of
them died
not enough to quarantine a camp in
wartime
but troop movements soon spread the flu
to many other army camps
24 of the 36 largest camps reported an
outbreak of flu in the spring of 1918
along with 30 of the country's 50
largest cities
but it was relatively mild if highly
contagious
the first wave of flu was so mild in
fact that several doctors
refused to believe it was even influenza
british doctors writing in the lancet
for example didn't think it was the flu
because the symptoms were too mild and
quote
a very short duration and so far absent
of relapses or complications
so soldiers from fort riley were loaded
onto troop ships by the
thousands in the last six months of
world war one over 1.5
million soldiers crossed the ocean to go
to war in europe
it was the largest such movement of
people in the history of the
world the troop ships were loaded to
capacity with young men
most of whom were fated to die in the
sausage grinder of the western front
but many of them were dead before they
even reached the shore
those overcrowded troop ships became
terrifying charnel houses
disgorging sick and dying soldiers by
the thousands
members of the 57th pioneer infantry
were already ill
with the flu and as they marched from
camp merritt new jersey
to board the troop ship leviathan they
soon began to drop out of ranks
trucks and ambulances scooped up those
too ill to continue but the rest
soldiered on by the time they reached
the ship
most of them had gone 24 hours without
sleep in several hours without food
and those sick and broken soldiers were
hurried on board
120 more were taken off the ship before
it departed
and they turned out to be the lucky ones
conditions aboard the troop ship
leviathan became
so bad a detail of soldiers actually
mutinied
rather than go below decks nighttime was
the worst
as one official report describes with
scenes that cannot be visualized by
anyone who has not
actually seen them the decks became wet
and slippery with blood
groans and cries of the terrified added
to the confusion of applicants clamoring
for treatment
and altogether a true inferno reigned
supreme
recently while touring the smithsonian
in dc i came across a scale model of the
leviathan and i was
floored i sat in front of it for half an
hour thinking of what had gone on
inside that ship but the leviathan that
you will see in the smithsonian
is the cruise ship before it became the
troop ship with people gaily waving from
the deck and confetti in the air
as everyone walked by i wanted to tell
them what had happened aboard that ship
but what a terrible thing to have
undergone of the estimated 2000 victims
on board at least
70 died on route 31 more the day at dock
and 14 more the following day
and many of the six soldiers fled the
death ship that the leviathan had become
as soon as their orders allowed
spreading the disease to fresh troops
hundreds more died on shore in the days
that followed
the 57th pioneer infantry one of the
units aboard the leviathan
recorded 195 flu deaths in a few days
after disembarking
and that scene was repeated over and
over and over again all throughout
england and europe
the troop carrier olympic 1947 troops
infected
over 140 died
no one was prepared to deal with
thousands of sick and dying men
confined in the living hell that those
troops ships became
the flu soon spread to french and
british troops and allied soldiers took
it home to civilians when they went on
leave
so the virus spread rapidly through
soldiers through pows and civilians
spreading to germany and russia and
china in india
southeast asia down into spain becoming
a true
global pandemic it was dubbed the
spanish flu but only because the press
started to take notice
as it happened to be hitting spain
the records of the 88th combat division
in france are typical
total combat casualties that's killed
wounded missing or captured
90 men total deaths from the flu
444
something happened aboard those troop
ships or maybe in the foul and crowded
trenches that
turned that flu into a savage killer
the second wave of an infection was now
poised to fall like a hammer blow
on an unsuspecting populace
why had this mild strain of flu suddenly
become so virulent
well several hypotheses have been
proposed a new and entirely different
strain had emerged
or perhaps a genetic mutation had
altered the original strain or maybe two
different viruses had fused together
to create a new strain and we'll briefly
consider each of those three
explanations
but before we can do that we need to
take a few minutes to consider how the
flu virus
actually works viruses are
mysterious little creatures they
generally consist of a core
of rna or dna surrounded by a membrane
or a capsule
rna is a single strand of genes and dna
is two complementary strands joined
together in that classic double helix
now unlike cells viruses can't replicate
by themselves they need to take over the
protein synthesis factory in a living
cell and reprogram it
to make copies of the virus
influenza is an rna virus with eight
separate genes enclosed in a membrane
covered with spikes
the virus is very very very small about
1
10 000 of a millimeter move over angels
viruses are so small that an area the
size of the head of a pin
could hold a billion of them
now there are two kinds of spikes on the
outside of the virus called h spikes
and n spikes and it's these spikes
incidentally that give the name for the
different types of flu like
h5n1 the h spikes
hemagglutinin cause red blood cells to
clump together or agglutinate
the n spikes are a type of enzyme
an enzyme is a catalyst that means it's
a protein that can
affect that can alter the course of a
chemical reaction we're going to talk a
lot more about catalysts and enzymes in
lecture 16 when we learn about aids
but the short version is it's like
putting a puzzle together on a tabletop
the table the enzyme isn't changed by
the act of assembling the puzzle
and it can be used over and over and
over again to help assemble
more puzzles the immune system in its
efforts to locate invaders looks for
unique groups of amino acids little
bits little fragments of proteins called
epitopes
molecules or cells that have epitopes in
their structure or on their surface
are called antigens remember those two
words epitope and antigen because
we're going to use them a lot and we're
going to learn a lot more about epitopes
and antigens
in our lectures on immunity
every organism has a different pattern
of epitopes sticking out on the surface
of its cells
that's actually kind of hard for us to
visualize because we think of cells as
these smooth little circles
maybe because that's the way the teacher
made us draw them in high school biology
lab
but in fact the outer surface of the
cell is a very complex surface
lots of little bits and pieces of
molecules and compounds sticking out in
all directions
and the immune system can recognize
these epitopes these little projections
as cellular id tags and uses them to
separate
self from non-self
both h and n spikes act as antigens as
do
two proteins that are inside the core of
the virus
and they can be readily identified by
the immune system
the two core antigens incidentally are
the same in all
type a flu viruses and are diagnostic
for type a flu
small changes in antigen structure are
called antigenic drift
and they create very similar strains
called variants
larger changes called antigenic shifts
create
different strains called subtypes and
it's these
major antigenic shifts in h n antigens
these new subtypes
that are responsible for major new
outbreaks of flu
when the virus attacks it sticks to the
outside of a cell by its h-spikes
the spikes lock onto a type of sialic
acid sugar that's found on the outside
of cells
in the lungs and in the throat and they
repeatedly bind to those cyalic acid
receptors
like a velcro strip or like tiny little
pirate grappling hooks
and i'm told that if you listen very
carefully with the stethoscope at this
stage
you can even hear all of those little
pirate r's
well that's why the flu is an upper
respiratory disease
it is specifically designed by evolution
to cling to a molecule
that protrudes from cells in the throat
and in the lungs
so here's the virus now stuck onto the
outside of a cell
it's absorbed into the cell through a
process of phagocytosis
in which small particles can literally
be surrounded by the cell membrane drawn
inside
leaving the particle wrapped in a tiny
little bubble of cell membrane called
a vesicle many other kinds of viruses
fuse themselves to the surface of the
cell in order to inject their contents
but this strategy leaves them open to
discovery by the immune system
by slipping inside the cell membrane
intact and by wearing the cell membrane
like a wolf in sheep's clothing
the flu virus makes itself invisible to
the many wandering immune system cells
that are scouting the body for trouble
once primed inside the cell the virus
sheds its envelope and releases its rna
genes
now what we refer to as a gene is simply
a series of coded instructions along a
length of dna
or rna that codes for putting together a
particular protein
and proteins are the building blocks of
life
each strand of rna or dna consists of a
long
series of genes which are basically
recipes for proteins
each separate gene is a separate recipe
it's kind of like
taking a file card box of recipes and
taping them end to end to end
that's how strands of dna and rna are
basically built
and while we're on the subject what we
call a chromosome
is really just a series of genes on a
single very long strand of dna
all coiled up into a tiny little package
we're going to learn a lot more about
how the instructions in dna are used to
make proteins
in lecture 16. now viruses contain
relatively few genes and these are
usually on a single strand of rna or dna
but the flu virus has multiple strands
of rna each
with only one or two genes the rna genes
of influenza
once primed and liberated in the cell
hijacked the cellular factory
replacing some of the host cells genes
and reprogramming the cell to make
thousands and thousands and thousands of
copies of the flu virus
the flu genes replicate and group
together in sets of eight
to form a new core and each set of eight
is wrapped up
in a fresh membrane and then they exit
the cell to spread the infection
within 10 hours of infection that cell
can release
100 000 to a million or more new flu
viruses
but theoretically new viruses should
become trapped as soon as they exit the
cell
by the same cyalic acid receptors that
they stuck to on the way in
that's where the end spikes the neuro
amenities spikes come into play
they have a blunt tip it's kind of like
a little box with four miniature
propeller blades
and these little blades slice through
the receptor sites as the virus emerges
from the cell
and prevent it from being stuck
now we can better answer the question we
posed earlier why did this mild strain
of flu suddenly become so
amazingly virulent was it a new and
entirely different strain
had the genetic mutation altered the
original strain
or did two different viruses fused
together to create an entirely new
strain
well the fact that survivors of the
first wave of the flu had some immunity
to later waves tells us
that the second wave wasn't an entirely
new strain but an altered form of the
virus that caused the first wave
so that re-energized strain might have
experienced a mutation
in its new host a mutation
is just a change in genetic information
a change in the recipe that determines
how
proteins are put together like your
chocolate chips are suddenly
butterscotch chips
and even a small change in the exterior
antigens of a microbe can cause the
immune system
to fail to recognize it anymore
and the influenza virus has an extremely
high rate of mutation makes it a real
genetic chameleon
from the standpoint of the immune system
now many mutations are stopped in their
tracks because dna has a built-in
proofreading mechanism so every time dna
is replicated for cell division it's
very carefully checked to make sure
everything is
as it should be but rna
lacks that proofreading mechanism so
mutations of rna
aren't repaired they aren't eliminated
and that means that an rna virus like
the flu
has a much higher mutation rate than a
dna virus
thousands and thousands of times higher
we call it
hypermutability and while mutations
provide the new variation that's
essential
for natural selection to work they come
with a cost
it's kind of like taking a hammer and
throwing it into a jet engine
you might get incredibly lucky and
change it for the better
more often than not you're going to
break it
and that means as many as 99 of the
newly created flu viruses are
basically damaged they can't infect
another cell
but that also means that between one
thousand to ten thousand viruses from
each infected cell
can not only still infect other cells
but may now be even more lethal than it
was before
and better able to hide from the immune
system
mutations are thought to be the
explanation for antigenic drift
small changes that create new variant
forms
but they can't adequately explain the
more dangerous antigenic shifts
where the virus becomes more radically
different
antigenic shifts like the change that
caused the second wave of the 1918 flu
to be so virulent
could result from the fusion of two
different types of flu viruses from
hybridization
now that seems rather a tall order how
can you jam two viruses together
but the way the flu virus reproduces
actually makes it relatively easy
remember that the eight genes of the
virus are on separate strands of rna so
if two subtypes if two
variants in fact the same cell at the
same time each is making thousands of
copies of its own
eight genes which are all now scrambled
up together inside the same
cell and when the genes are reassembled
in groups of eight to form a new core
and sealed into a fresh viral envelope
the two types can very easily mix
together
so the new virus will still have all
eight genes that it needs to survive but
those eight genes
are now going to be a random mixture of
the genes of both types
of the flu virus it's only by
reconstructing the virus that we can
determine its origin and test
this hybridization hypothesis about its
virulence and we're going to talk a lot
more
about that hybridization hypothesis in
our final lecture
on the flu well the virus could also
have strengthened simply through
passage from host to host it's easy to
demonstrate in the lab that as a new
virus
infects new victims it somehow seems
initially to strengthen
with each passage something we don't
really understand
it may be that each new passage provides
a fresh opportunity for mutation or
hybridization
we really don't know
in the end we don't know where the
killer flu of 1918 came from
maybe it was born from the war itself
taking advantage of that new ecosystem
presented by trench warfare
john oxford claims that it first emerged
in a massive field hospital complex in
etoble in northwest france
in the winter of 1915 and 1916.
the symptoms were much like those of the
later pandemic and the area had a lot of
goose and duck and pig
farms that could very easily have
harbored the virus plus it had 24
varieties of mutagenic
chemical warfare gas there was little
doubt however that the
killer flu of the fall was a close
relative of the bug that had swept
through the previous spring because
survivors of the first
wave of the flu were moderately immune
to the second wave
and now the flu struck with an amazing
intensity
fevers ran so high that doctors often
misdiagnosed the flu as malaria
the usual bone pains and joint pains
were so severe some doctors thought they
were dealing with dengue fever
also known as break bone fever symptoms
included severe earaches and headaches
the victims often bled heavily from the
nose the mouth the eyes the ears
the lung damage was so severe that
doctors compared it to the damage done
by mustard gas
pockets of gas actually bubbled up under
the skin from the ruptured lungs of the
victims
the immune system reaction was so strong
that it often created a disastrous
feedback loop something we call a
cytokine storm
it's the immune system version of a
nuclear attack we'll talk more about the
roles of cytokines in our two lectures
on immunity
well cytokine storms can destroy the
ability of the lungs to exchange gas
and that severe lung damage led to
cyanosis
a blue coloration of the skin caused by
the lack of oxygen in the blood
victims were stained so darkly in some
cases it was hard to tell black men from
white
and that extreme cyanosis fueled rumors
amongst the soldiers that the flu in
fact was really the black death
autopsies on victims revealed extensive
damage to the lungs
the heart and the brain and that's
rather strange because
flu isn't normally associated with
neurological problems
but victims of the 1918 flu were often
left with permanent nerve damage
and even psychosis
the 1918 flu virus also attached to
cells lining the lungs
not just the cells in the upper
respiratory tract as it usually does
and we'll learn why in our last lecture
on the flu
and this left people open to secondary
lung infections
in fact pneumonia in the weak and flu
victims was often the bigger killer
pneumonia is a general sort of word it
can be caused by bacteria but it's
really
a term for lung damage of any type
that's due to viral or bacterial or even
chemical sources
casualty figures for the fall of 1918
show the brutal power of that renewed
virus
in decimating the american the british
and the french allied forces
in september october and november of
1918
the american expeditionary forces
recorded nearly 112
000 military hospital admissions for flu
or related pneumonia
with over 9 000 deaths french forces
admitted about 132 000 with over
10 000 deaths and the british forces 63
000 victims 3 600 dead
that's a total of over 307
000 flu casualties in three months
with nearly 23 000 dead
and we'll never know how many thousands
or tens of thousands more
died where they lay in the endless
foxholes and trenches of the front
the eight and a half million lost in the
war to end all wars
beside the more than 50 million lost
worldwide in our battle with the flu
now unlike earlier epidemics which took
their toll on the very young and the
very old
this one took full aim at people in the
prime of
life john m berry estimates that 5 to 10
percent of the world's young adults died
in that epidemic
the 1918 flu wasn't the usual u-shaped
curve that was
a w shaped so we had our usual mortality
among the very young but in those middle
age groups where it's usually pretty
flat it spikes up very very sharply
in the 15 to 34 age category and then
down again until it hits
old age why did so many young adults die
we're going to explore the answer to
that in our final lecture
on the 1918 flu well now we know how the
flu virus is structured
we know how it infects cells we know how
it hides from the immune system so we're
going to be better prepared to
appreciate our detective story that
we're going to weave in a later lecture
the search for a living virus but first
we'll witness the return of the now
transformed and deadly flu
from europe to america and we'll take a
look at the city of philadelphia
as a case study of the american
experience with the pandemic
and as an illustration of how society
responds to a medical crisis
you